daisy hello
[Applause]
[Music]
if you'd like it sure
that the temperature doesn't continue to
rise the same way it does now
and for that we have to reduce carbon emissions to zero
by 2050
why and I  would like to put that
in a law like that we force all
the member states of the european union
to take measures which leads to
this situation which is enormously
complicated but which is absolutely
necessary for our future and why
2050 why not 2060 2070  why
because it requires a
fairly fundamental transformation of
our society of our economy
and we know from history that
such a transformation truffle
we need a generation of a
generation so if we want we look
now from here  2050 is exactly
one generation and so we will have your
generation your generation will be leading the way
in creating this change so is
what you do here at school is
really important to be aware
of the fact that we really have to change and
that we can't continue to live as
we do now
and it's also very important that's
why I asked that you make
these changes  at home with your family and
that your parents understand that it's the
future of their childhood and for you who
do that not or an abstraction that
would be the country the planet no it's for
you it's your future that is at stake
we  we also put a lot of hopes
in this meeting for several
reasons we think at school can
finally not that we many people
tell us we are facing a huge challenge
in belgium we consume four
planets four times more resources
than the earth can generate  and this is a
real problem
we think that at another level each
citizen each organization has
efforts to make and we are trying here
to apply this method but we
are convinced that the framework must
evolve the framework in  established by the
public authorities must evolve to
support this movement
it was the message of the young people
who demonstrated last year for the
climate we arrived we have a project with
goodplanet and that team it was really
super cool and well  the two of us have stayed
committed this year, it's their vegetable garden
that is important to me because
I already like everything that is
manual, everything that involves manual work, I
've put things in place for you, but also at the
same time.  time and for the school suddenly I
tried to put that at home also for
sustainable development is what
I like in the vegetable garden is that we
can learn things while
producing so what we  needs to
live and not have overconsumption
and yes you learn Muslims here it's
really important to be aware
of the fact that we really have to change and
that we can't continue to live as
we do now
and it's also  very important that's
why I  I asked that you make
these changes at home with your family and
that your parents understand that this is the
future of their childhood and for you who
are doing this not for an abstraction which
would be the country the planet no it's for
you it's  is your a little bit quiet
normally useful for chicory
six larger ones and so the smaller
ones also come in retains we can
do things with the large ones
because sometimes the small ones are a little put
on the investor side
every week this  year then we
do rotations
so we use the serv offered all
and all our cultures
the maximum we ourselves who are
telling me go ahead it's a shame to
come to this logic but humor
it was  very quickly
well yes it makes sense clearly we
reuse everything that comes out of the kitchen
ends up in the compost bins
obviously everything that can go in
the compost bins and therefore we no
longer waste because now
the economy  ie is based on resources
that we use to make
something and then we throw that away it's no longer
possible because we no longer have the
resources too much forced the blue planet
all year round with all the actors of
the  school like anna explained to you
earlier we really tried to
[Laughs] the
press or students
carole who prepares them leaving the night
here is a sentence that somewhat sums up our
philosophy was to redirect our
to the consequences that the redemption can
have we  decided to display we know
who benefits
if we think that the problem is
currently behind when we
buy something that was in
September it is indeed we do not know
who benefits what are the
consequences  social environmental
this is where it's happening this
is the case this is
martine marie josée carole and mr
wheat who is preparing his bombs
how much sandwich i am at 200 days says
i think percent but we still
had 15 to  20  % more meals in mind that
it doesn't come from the vegetable garden but not impossible
I learned a lot
am proud of you as a father and and
I really would like you to have more courage
and to continue giving you a
really very important example you really have to
'we change the way we see our
world and I believe that this school
teaches you to look at having a
different look at everyday life especially
what we do what we eat how to
move here maybe how we
establish  relations with others and I
find it impressive and I believe that
you have you have the future of the world
in your hands and if you continue
like this I become more optimistic
than before this morning so thank you for that
thank you for teaching me  thank you
very much